ces deux là bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin
l'heure on a bien vu un les annonces
hier du ministre de la santé olivier
vers en un tour de vis sévère dans
certaines régions notamment à marseille
et en guadeloupe pour séculière 11
grandes villes où les alertes ou
l'alerté renforcée avec des mesures
sanitaires encore plus contraignantes
on a l'impression que l'on se dirige
vers un deuxième confinement est d'abord
votre avis alors chez que bien sûr il ya
des projections épidémiologique sur les
mobilisations et si on ne fait rien
effectivement on va aller vers un état
d'urgence sanitaire et je pense que
lorsque j'entends quelques politiques
pour pour une question d'
instrumentalisation et bien il faut
demander aux gens qui sont passés par la
réanimation et qui savent de quoi de
quoi nous parlons
donc je pense que olivier ferrand a
appelé à un sursaut national et à la
responsabilisation de chacun voilà c'est
mon sentiment est à ce niveau là bien
sûr sur marseille j'ai entendu quelques
reportages
si on peut déplorer lorsque vous êtes
patron d'un bar ou d'un restaurant les
problèmes économiques les risques bien
sûr ils seront accompagnés et bruno le
maire prendra les mesures nécessaires
comme elle ont été prises lors du du
confinement les mesures justement que ce
soit marseille on voit de nouveau
d'ailleurs dans les zones où d'alert
renforcer la fermeture totale pour les
zones en alerte maximale des bars et
restaurants
ailleurs c'est à partir de 22h alors on
sait que les clusters ce qu'ils ont été
détectés récemment c'était plutôt
pendant les réunions familiales et là on
ferme de nouveaux justement les bars et
les restaurants s et c'est un petit peu
paradoxal à mesure douze mois il faut il
faut savoir que de toute façon pas au
moins moi j'habite en réalité alors on
va pas demander à celui qui baisse son
jardin quand le rouge-gorge le regard de
qu'il met un masque mais dans dix zones
de forte concentration de population
comme dans les métropoles mais dans les
bars et les restaurants où ce sont des
zones de convivialité on a tendance à
relâcher son attention les gestes de
préconisations par contre je pensais à
cette publicité traite bien fait ou on
voit justement une famille heureuse de
se retrouver et puis juste après la
personne qui fête son anniversaire se
retrouver en rénovation non je pense
qu'il faut être responsable et en tant
que médecin moi je me suis engagé
pendant le confinement dans la réserve
sanitaire
je pense qu'il faut pas affoler les
patients on a on a amélioré les les
prises en charge l'organisation de même
les protocoles sanitaires
vous le savez bien il y avait on a eu
quand même beaucoup de décès en mars
actuellement celui ou celle qui est
atteinte du duc au vide avec des
complications a deux fois plus de
chances entre guillemets de s'en sortir
tant mieux maintenant effectivement tant
que nous n'avons pas le vaccin
les mesures qui sont préconisées elles
sont temporaires comme l'a dit le
ministre s'est réévalué c'est pour deux
semaines
et puis ça dépend du taux d'incidence
sur marseille et la guadeloupe
vous avez un taux d'incidence c'est à
dire le nombre de cas ces 250 cas la
zone d' alerte et très élevé 250 cas
pour 100000 habitants et surtout il faut
pas oublier les personnes âgées c'est
plus de 100 cas pour 100000 habitants
donc les mesures qui sont prises
notamment dans les ehpad
on n'est pas là pour l'isolément des
personnes âgées noix de l'inde
on a même moi qui suis au conseil
consultatif national d'éthique rendu une
saisine sur le sujet au premier ministre
li ya trois mois mais il faut aussi être
attentif et surtout protéger
fragile donc de toutes façons vous
alliez dans les bars ou les restaurants
quand vous avez un taux d'incidence y
est élevé vous pouvez transmettre à des
êtres qui vous sont chers dont on
appelle à la responsabilité
certains pays ont même utilisé le mot
deuxième vague est ce le cas pour la
france
alors bon on vous dit vous avez vous
savez il ya plusieurs un petit peu bon
on compare alors on a une règle alors
langage très guerrier en ai dit que
c'était une bataille d'une guerre contre
le virus
là on emprunte un langage plus marin
mais pour avoir vu olivier derand encore
avant-hier soir et aussi avoir participé
puisque je suis aussi je fais partie de
l'assemblée parlementaire franco
allemande à une vidéoconférence avec les
ministres franco allemand
je peux vous dire que holly des verts en
tient bon la barre c'est je crois qu on
reconnaît le capitaine lorsqu'il ya des
avis de tempête lorsque le bateau tangue
cela étant les mesures et puis la
pédagogie du ministre parce que les
français comprennent parfaitement bien
les fameuses courbes mais de toute façon
on peut les infléchir on peut les
infléchir parce que il faut ramener
justement selon de reproduction le
fameux air en dessous de 1 il c'est
possible on l'a fait pendant le
confinement est actuellement on n'est
pas dans cette urgence sanitaire mais on
en a tous les moyens justement pour
revenir à des effets refluer la la
propagation du virus
dernière question vous parlais justement
du nombre r c'est l'un des critères qui
est prise en compte par les autorités
c'est à dire le taux d'incidence dans la
population générale
c'est le cas de le cas hebdomadaires
pardon pour pour cent mille habitants
mais aujourd'hui
on sait qu'il y à de nombreuses
personnes qui se font tester donc est ce
un petit peu normal aussi que l'on se
retrouve avec ce taux d'incidence a
élevé alors effectivement plus vous
multipliez les tests plus vous avez plus
vous avez eu un taux qui s'élève alors
il se faut savoir qu'actuellement le
taux de positivité il est il était à 5
5,2 il ya une semaine il est
actuellement à 6,1 et pour autant c'est
lakovic 19 s'il voulait ça peut être
aussi des porteurs sains et donc le
multiplier les tests en attend aussi des
tests anti unique toujours par
prélèvement nasopharyngé féringiens ou
salivaire multiplié les tests c'est une
bonne chose justement puisqu'on est
toujours dans la procédure des pistes et
alerter tester et isolé avec toutes les
mesures nécessaires et moi je salue lens
mène le travail des agences régionales
de santé qui est conséquent et je peux
vous dire au ministère de la santé et
ils travaillent 24 heures sur 24 sur le
sujet pour alerter et accompagner les
gens qui serait positif on a par exemple
à l'assemblée nationale on a eu quatre
cas de positif de mes collègues
parlementaires ils se sont tout de suite
isolé et même bruno le maire a été testé
positif la semaine dernière
merci beaucoup d'avoir à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste et député de la 4e
circonscription de l'aisne